s
à connaître au fil des deux
dernières années?
Normand Grondin
à préparé ceci...
- On va se l
(rires)
Ça va être fantastique.
- C'est plus que la normale,
on est hyper excité pour Noël.
- Moi et ma famille, on va faire
une grosse fête, là, toute
la famille au Vietnam, on vient.
- Les fêtes dans deux semaines
et pour bien des gens, une chose
est claire : la pandémie,
c'est terminée.
- On est d'origine grecque,s s e
beaucoup, on danse beaucoup.
- On va faire comme on faisait
dans le temps; on va se
rassembler puis, je pense qu'on
va essayer d'oublier la COVID.
- Pas de précacececececece
qu'on est en famille et
on est vaccinés.
- Pourtant, en ce moment même,
le nombre de cas de COVID,
de virus d'enfants et
d'influenza est plus éle
qu'à pareille date l'an passé.
Donc, est-ce que la prudence
devrait encore freiner
nos plan des fêtes?
Nous avons sondé demandé
l'opinion de qrtrtrtrtrtrts
des virus respiratoires.
Conclusion : eux aussi sont pas
mal plus détendus qu'en 2021.
93 % d'entre eux affirment
que cette année, ils vont fêter
en famille, mais aussi fêter
avec leurs collègues.
Dr KARL WEISS, microbiologiste-
infectiologue, Hôpital gén. juif
- Moi, je pense qu'on est rendus
à l'étape où les fêtes 2022
devront êtetetetetetetes
que les gens ont passé dans
le passé, avant la pandémie.
Donc, on est revenu à une vie
normale.
- 87 % des répondants se disent
également prêt à participer
à un grand événement extérieur
sans masque et même à un grand
événement intérieur, mais
avec masque. C'est le signe,
selon spécialistes de la santé
publique, que la perception
du risque a aussi évolué
chez les spécialistes.
NIMÂ MACHOUF, épidémio., chargée
d'ens. de clinique , ÉSPUM
- Ce qui s'est passé, c'est
la vaccination qui est très
largement utilisée, de un,
et de titititititititions qu'on
subi les virus et qui font en
sorte que maintenant,
c'est très difficile de
les empêcher de circuler.
Et le virus, il est devenu trop
fort, il se transmet trop
facilement. Il est devenu plus
fort que nous à ce niveau
- Le Dr Weiss est du même avis.
- C'est une dynamique,
la maladie infectieuse. Donc,
c'est un phénomène dynamique,
c'est-à-dire qu'à un momenté,é,r
des masques de façon massive,
extrême et intense, mais
un moment donné, il faut savoir
s'adapter à une situation qui a
changé et qu.........
- Par contre, au quotidien,
plusieurs experts préfèrent
rester prudents :
Un répondant sur trois évite
encore les restaurants;
73 % portent un masque
dans les transports en commun;
et 60 % en faisantcececececece.
- Les gens imunosupprimés,
ils n'ont pas le choix
faire leur marché. Les parents
de jeunes enfants de 1-2 mois,
ils n'ont pas le choix d'y
aller. Il faut bien qu'ils
soient là. Ça fait que le plus
qu'on va diminuer la charge
de sécrétions infectieuses
dans leur environnement,
et le moins ils ont de cha
de s'infecter.
- Je pense que c'est avoir
une mémoire courte de penser
qu'on est de retour
à la normale.
- Tout est pas fini à 100 %,
donc il faut toujours se
pr
- Joyeux Noël!
- En ce qui concerne les fête
en famille, nos experts sont
unanimes : on doit refuser
tous les invités qui voudraient
se présenter avec des symptômes
viraux.auauauauauauauauauaudrait
le monde : "si on est malade,
on ne se présente pas dans
une fête de famille." Comme
si on est malade, on porte
le masque.
- 40 % de nos spécialistes
disent aussi qu'ils vont fermer
la portet t t t t t t t t t pas
reçu de vaccin depuis six mois,
et le tiers, qu'ils vont
demander à leurs invités
de passer un test COVID
avant le Réveillon. On a aus
posé la même question au grand
public.
- On va les tester, on va mettre
les tests sur le bord de
la porte.
- Ouin, c'est ça!
- On va mettre les tests, puis,,
on sort la bière.
(rires)
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
-